[Music]
it is known that there are hundreds of
Mickey Mouse heads hidden throughout
every Disney movie but if you were too
busy trying to count all the Mickey
heads you may have missed some other and
more clever Disney Easter eggs if you
are a first-time viewer click the red
subscribe button and enjoy today we are
discussing 10 hidden details you never
noticed in Disney movies fly my pretties
the Disney movie creators are known to
reference other Disney movies with
special cameos and easter eggs but there
was one scene in Disney's Hunchback of
Notre Dame that referenced a legendary
Hollywood movie that has nothing to do
with Disney during the scene The
Gargoyle Laverne
releases her birds and yells fly my
pretties if this sentence sounds
familiar that because it's the same one
the Wicked Witch of the West screamed
when she released her flying monkeys in
The Wizard of Oz the prized cameos
Disney directors Ron Clements and John
Musker have directed several Disney
classics though you may not be able to
put a face to their names you may be
surprised that you have probably seen
them without even knowing it the
directors love to put hidden cameras of
themselves in their films they were
peasants in Aladdin robots and Treasure
Island and even threw beads from a Mardi
Gras float in The Princess and the Frog
sells blue dress you've probably seen
Belle's blue dress hundreds of times and
didn't give it a second thought but the
movies costume designers had very
specific reasons for making Belle's
dress blue this is in history of female
movie heroines wearing blue this is
because the color blue symbolizes that
these women including Belle's are
dependable reliable and consistent it
should also be noted that Belle is the
only person who wears blue in her
village which shows just how different
she really is real-life inspiration you
may know that real-life castles inspired
many of the castles from Disney movies
but did you know famous people inspired
some of the characters in Disney movies
you may have never put Aladdin and Tom
Cruise together but when you do a
side-by-side you can see where Disney
got their inspiration
everyone's favorite little mermaid was
modeled after photos of actress Alyssa
Milano when she was younger and then
there are the vultures in the jungle
book who were inspired by the Beatles as
they were intended to voice them but
cancelled because of a scheduled
conflict
special guest it's not unusual for
Disney characters to show up in other
Disney movies but usually they don't
interact with any of the main characters
like when the Duke and the King from
Cinderella were in attendance at Prince
Eric's wedding there were also a few
Disney favorites that attended Elsa's
coronation in frozen newlyweds Rapunzel
and Flynn from tangled make a quick
cameo as well as Tiana from Princess and
the Frog little brother doll if you
blinked at all during this scene in
Tarzan you may have missed a cute hidden
detail the scene starts by Jane
introducing her dad and bodyguard to the
ape the Apes then pick up Jane's dad the
professor and random things start to
fall out of his pocket what you may have
missed is that one of these random
things is a small white and brown doll
also known as little brother
Mulan's pet dog the different parts of
Beast over the years many people have
wondered what exactly is beast we know
he is part monster part animal but the
answer is actually way more complicated
beast is a combination of seven
different animals his name is from a
lion his beard and head comes from a
buffalo his brow is from a gorilla he
kept his human eyes his tusks are from a
wild boar his body is the same as a bear
and his legs and tail are from a wolf a
113 if you've watched Disney and Pixar
films chances are you have seen the
number a 113 hidden in several of their
films it's seen on the front of a
trolley in Princess and the Frog and
it's on a camera in Finding Nemo to name
a few
but what exactly does this symbolize and
why does it keep showing up it turns out
that a 113 is the number of the
animation classroom at the California
Institute of the Arts where many of the
Disney Pixar animators went to school
Rapunzel loves princesses in the movie
tangles the animators made sure to let
audiences know that Rapunzel is a huge
Disney Princess fan
she shares the same spinning wheel as
Aurora from Sleeping Beauty she also
included the Disney princess in her
interior decorating when you zoom in on
Rapunzel's banisters you can see each
banister has a different symbol
representing of different Disney
Princess there is a glass slipper for
Cinderella a rose for Belle and a
seashell for Ariel Moana Easter eggs
mallanna is one of Disney's newest
movies and the makers of the film stay
true to Disney's Easter egg dropping
form in one scene Maui transforms
himself into several characters while
trying to rescue Moana from a giant crab
one of those characters include Sen the
adorable reindeer from frozen Moana also
gave several nods to Disney classic
little mermaids like when the giant crab
claims to be helped by a crab named
Sebastian with a cool Jamaican accent
and when flounder swam across the screen
during Maui's opening song you're
welcome have you ever noticed these
details hidden in Disney movies react in
the comment section below and don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
to the thing
[Music]